I WILL GO.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
GUESS WHAT IS GOING ON?
GUESS THAT THE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL
CONTINUES THIS HOUR, THE LEGAL
TEAM CURRENTLY SPEAKING.
WE WILL DIP AND LIVE IF ANYTHING
NEWSWORTHY HAPPENS.
THINK BACK TO 2016.
DONALD TRUMP USED TO RECITE A
POEM ABOUT A WOMAN WHO TOOK A
DYING SNAKE INTO HER HOUSE AND
NURSE DATES BACK TO HEALTH.
THE SNAKE TO BECOME HEALTHY AND
THEN WHIPPED AROUND AND BIT THE
WOMAN, AS SHE BREATHED HER LAST
BREATH, THE WOMAN ASKED TO THE
SNAKE, WIDE DID YOU DO THIS?
BECAUSE I AM A SNAKE WAS THE
REPLY, THAT’S WHAT WE DO.
ALL OF WHICH SOMEHOW REMINDS US
OF DISGRACED SECURITY ADVISOR
JOHN BOLTON.
REPUBLICANS IN WASHINGTON
SHOCKED TO DISCOVER THAT
JOHN BOLTON HAS BETRAYED HIS
FORMER BOSS PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BUT THEY SHOULD NOT BE SHOCKED.
THAT’S WHO JOHN BOLTON IS.
THAT’S WHO JOHN BOLTON HAS
ALWAYS BEEN.
THAT’S WHAT JOHN BOLTON DOES.
AND NOT TO BRAG, BUT WE CALLED
IT LONG AGO.
LAST YEAR "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REPORTED THAT JOHN BOLTON’S BOOK
DESIGN SECTIONS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
ACCUSING THE PRESIDENT OF
DELAYING MILITARY TO UKRAINE TO
PRESSURE THE GOVERNMENT INTO
INVESTIGATING HUNTER BIDEN.
AGAIN, PEOPLE IN WASHINGTON SEEM
STUNNED BY THIS OR CLAIM TO BE.
IF BOLTON DISLIKE TRUMP SO MUCH,
WHY DID HE JOIN THE
ADMINISTRATION?
THE ANSWER IS SIMPLE.
BOLTON WANTED WAR WITH IRAN, HE
HAS ALWAYS WANTED WAR WITH IRAN,
HE IS OBSESSED WITH IT.
HERE HE IS GLEEFULLY LOOKING AT
CHANGE THERE LONG BEFORE HE
BECAME A NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISER.
>> I HAVE SAID FOR OVER TEN
YEARS SINCE COMING TO THESE
EVENTS THAT THE DECLARED POLICY
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
SHOULD BE THE OVERTHROW OF THE
MULLAHS REGIME IN TEHRAN.
AND THAT’S WHY BEFORE 2019 WE
HEAR WILL CELEBRATE IN TEHRAN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> Tucker: IN TEHRAN!
BUT IRAN WAS NOT THE ONLY
TARGET.
AND WHEN AND MORE WAR IN SYRIA
AND VENEZUELA.
ONE OF THE WAR IN AFGHANISTAN TO
CONTINUE UNTIL YOUR GREAT GROWN
CHILDREN ARE TO OLD TO SERVE.
AND HE WANTED WAR WITH RUSSIA!
LOTS OF IT.
IN 2016 BOLTON CITED RUSSIA AS
ONE OF AMERICA’S GREATEST THAT’S
THE LIMIT THREATS.
FOR BOLTON, EVERY CONFLICT WAS
THE FINAL TEST OF AMERICANS
RESOLVE AND A CHANCE TO USE
MILITARY FORCE.
MAYBE BECAUSE HE NEVER SERVED IN
THE MILITARY HIMSELF, BOLTON
PASSIONATELY LOVED WAR.
IN THE END HE DID NOT GET IT.
TRUMP LOCKED HIM AT THE BRINK OF
MORE THAN ONE CONFLICT.
HE FINALLY LEFT IN WELL-DESERVED
HUMILIATION.
BOLTON’S RESIGNATION WAS ONE OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS OF THE
PRESIDENT’S FIRST TERM.
THE CELEBRATION FOR NORMAL
PEOPLE EVERYWHERE.
BUT NOT IN AMERICA’S NEWSROOMS.
THE MEDIA WERE SAD TO SEE
JOHN BOLTON GO.
THEY LOVE WARS.
WARS MEAN THEY CAN MOVE TANKS
AROUND ON THE SCREEN AND TALK
ABOUT WEAPON SYSTEMS.
SO SUDDENLY FOR THE FIRST TIME
THEY LOVE TO JOHN BOLTON.
WHAT I HEAR HERO HE WAS.
>> BOLTON IS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT, HE WAS ONE OF THEM.
HE IS NOT PRONE TO JUST LYING.
>> AND YOU HAVE TO GIVE HIM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT ON
CREDIBILITY, BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT TO SERVE ZERO.
>> IT DID FEEL LIKE WE WERE
MOCKING TIME AND THIS WAS
BECOMING A PLANNED ACQUITTAL.
AND YET WE HAVE A PERRY MASON
MOMENT.
>> WHO ARE YOU GOING TO BELIEVE?
DONALD TRUMP OR JOHN BOLTON?
YOU COULD BELIEVE PROBABLY A
DEAD FROG MORE THAN YOU COULD
BELIEVE TRUMP AT THIS POINT.
>> BOLTON IS A LOT OF THINGS,
BUT ABLE TO BE PAINTED AS THE
DEEP STATE ACTOR IS NOT ONE OF
THEM.
SO GOOD LUCK WITH THAT.
REPUBLICANS CAN NOW EXHALE AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE EARTH IS
ROUND AND THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
CORRUPT.
THEY CAN RELY ON A MAN WHO IS A
REPUBLICAN VERSION OF
JUSTICE SCALIA.
A CONSERVATIVE CONSERVATIVE.
>> Tucker: A CONSERVATIVE’S
CONSERVATIVE SAYS A LIBERAL.
THE ONLY THING JOHN BOLTON
HELPED CONSERVE WAS BEYOND STOCK
PRICES.
HE DID A GOOD JOB THERE.
THE CONFLICTS ARE NOT
CONSERVATIVE, THEY ARE JUST THE
OPPOSITE OF THAT.
THEY ARE A BIG RAISE IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS IS DYING.
THAT SEEMS OBVIOUS TO YOU.
IT IS NOT OBVIOUS HERE.
IN WASHINGTON, PRODUCTIVE WARS
ARE A VIRTUE NOT A VICE.
JUST ASK MITT ROMNEY, ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHAMPIONS.
OVER A WEEK AGO AND THE SENATE,
ROMNEY MADE AN BIG LAMENT NOISE
ABOUT TESTIFYING TO THE
PUBLIC.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO WILL NOT
BE NAMED?
I’M NOT SURE, NOT REALLY
NECESSARY.
BUT JOHN BOLTON, MITT ROMNEY
WOULD LOVE TO SEE JOHN BOLTON
TESTIFY BEFORE CONGRESS.
KEEP IN MIND THAT BOLTON WAS
ONCE A SENIOR CORRESPONDENT
ADVISOR TO ROMNEY’S DOOMED
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
AND THEY ARE STILL FRIENDS.
>> I THINK THE STORY THAT CAME
DOUBT YESTERDAY IS INCREASINGLY
APPARENT THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
HEAR FROM JOHN BOLTON.
I THINK IT IS VERY FAIR TO SAY
THAT JOHN BOLTON HAS A RELEVANT
TESTIMONY TO THOSE WHO ARE
SITTING IN IMPARTIAL JUSTICE.
>> Tucker: WILL JOHN BOLTON
TESTIFY?
WHO KNOWS?
EITHER WAY WILL CHANGE THE
OUTCOME.
IF TRUMP WILL BE ACQUITTED.
IT IS A STUPID SIDESHOW.
WE WILL BE EMBARRASSED BY IT
LATER.
BUT IF THEY CAN THINK ABOUT
JOHN BOLTON HIMSELF FOR A MOMENT
ANYWAY, HOW DID A GUY WHO
DISAGREE SO COMPLETELY WITH
EVERYTHING DONALD TRUMP RAN ON
AN WON ON, HOW DID HE WIND UP IN
A POSITION OF POWER IN THE